so for those that that don't know so
June God is medical he's a medical
doctor with training from Harvard Duke
and Stanford and then he's the president
of Palo Alto investors with 2.5 billion
dollar hedge fund in healthcare
investments and then he is the sponsor
of the Palo Alto longevity prize and so
and lastly this is interesting last
thing that I wasn't aware of the two
million dollar national academy
longevity grand challenge and so that
was a grant that you gave them in order
to to put great minds together to crack
into this aging and longevity yes it's
gone national and global so it's great
really delayed this happening this is
awesome to have you yeah June is an
inspiration to me I called frequently
Calma Polymathic yesterday he shattered
my mind in like four different ways one
of the ways that he shot could keep
shattering my mind about this topic is
like I'm always trying to run around and
tell people about world peace and when I
came up to June I was like June we got
to get there we're gonna get World Peace
and what was your response and why do
you think this way
I'm a Toby fine it'll be great and the
first thing that happened after World
Peace
it'll probably a civil war so the thing
that you know there's an old idea and
evolution biology called group selection
and that idea kind of got crushed by
biologists you know several decades ago
and it's now back again multi-level
selection is that right way to think
about it that selection it's not just
operating at the gene level not just at
the individual level but even at the
society level that societies that have
certain features that have can
accelerate evolution or probably gonna
outdo others so when you look at the
Cambrian radiation the fact that they're
predator and prey both existed forced
all the organisms to develop better
communication systems and better
mobilization better defense that's when
the verticals came out so there was
massive speciation so evolution actually
prefers that we don't agree so the last
thing evolution wants is the neutral
consensus it was
us to constantly look at things multiple
ways in radiology we call that parallax
we're not seeing things in the same
perspective actually improves your
ability to see so now we might it might
not feel good for us to be around people
that disagree but from a group selection
perspective or multi-level selection
perspective it is better for this system
better for the group better for society
that we don't see eye to eye this is the
genius of the male-female divide we have
different agendas and that actually
forces us to think harder right so
that's why every species has at least
two genders it actually drives active
selection of ideas so and so don't think
about the fact that we disagree as a
necessarily a bug it's actually a future
it's a feature but then it can sometimes
go awry we don't want to be annihilating
each other because we disagree but we
definitely don't want to get into group
thing it concessive because that's
dangerous evolution does not want
consensus that's fascinating to me
there's no instances of consensus among
either one species or no there is yeah
so when you get back into consensus when
you stop disagreeing is when there's now
somebody on the outside you want
disagree with so nothing unites a group
more than an external enemy so one of
the hopes out of the longevity
initiative is just to recognize this is
the biggest humanitarian crisis out
there is the fact that 500,000 people
around the world exit from aging related
diseases per week this is the largest
humanitarian crisis in history so we
don't have to go look for an enemy exit
right there exit a que die yeah five
hundred thousand a week that's crazy
that's Alzheimer's and cancer heart
disease yeah all aging related diseases
so I mean that's per week so every week
we wait that's another half a million
gone forever
so this is a race against time guys and
this is a common enemy whatever our
differences there's a larger enemy out
there so evolution also wants us to stop
fighting when there's an external enemy
so both will do things there features
when there's no external enemy we will
divide when there is an enemy we will
unite so let's not to use this to our
advantage a really simple way to
understand the parallax is the male
species like you said that's a and red
blue there's everywhere you know you'll
see like like look at blockchain it go
some Bitcoin you know - I mean there's
gonna be fragmentation and that's not a
good thing it actually creates
speciation it creates diversity and
makes the whole system more robust even
though as an individual member and there
it doesn't feel as good what are some of
gene unions core values this is a this
is how I govern my day in my year in my
life so it's a good starting point I
gotta always decide because we all are
facing tons of demands and ton tons of
opportunity so what do you base your
decisions on and everybody can have
different values and it's you know all
comes down to how you live against your
values
so very simple values on my end trust
respect unconditional love when I think
about trust being trustworthy trusting
others trusting in yourself this
confidence respect I have a more of an
old-school of your respect this which is
that respect is something you give I
learned that from my grandfather it's
not something you get it's something you
give so he was the village leader I come
from a rice farming family and he was a
village leader so normally in Korean
culture you bow deeper to your elder and
he did the opposite he would bow deeper
to everyone in the village so I never
told me what he was doing but I inferred
that oh you know respect is something
you give and then when you start
thinking about getting respect that's
when you start actually it eats away at
your soul you start thinking about
disrespect how I was disrespected as a
foundation of gang hood as a founder
around a tional resentment as long as
you think about respect or something
that's out but never occur to you to
have those kind of like weird feelings
unconditional love you know I think the
conditional love is totally fine I mean
I think that's reciprocal altruism but
when you do it without strings is when
you really unlock people and probably
yourself too in communities so I think
that's the less common thing so I think
that's the that's the foundation of a
lot of the great things that are
happening around the world that I see
and that's what I try to practice as
well those are great great core values
and
definitely some that I think many people
practice and we will slowly practice
more of June this is something that he
taught me just a couple like weeks ago
the itami that you were like Alan where
you focused on and I was telling you
like 17 different things and you were
like well like why are you focusing on
so many different things I'm like well
because there's so many interesting
things and I really want to focus on
them and learn about them but then you
were like well why what about focusing
on things that you're you have a lot of
fear of missing out on those things and
you see so much opportunity and so many
things we're about focusing on just a
couple what do you focus on and how do
you decide on what to focus on so I
think people are people in this room
anyway are blessed with an abundance of
opportunities and not everybody around
the world has opportunities and I think
we need to get them opportunities
hopefully they'll find their way and I
think our jobs set the table for a lot
of people who will be able to thrive but
in the valley for sure opportunity
obesity is a massive problem so we've
all heard of caloric obesity you know
we're wired for scarcity opportunity
obesity that's what that it's the same
it's the same same underlying trait the
inability to say no because we'll wire
for scarcity we're wired for not having
enough calories
so now that the industry can provide us
lots of calories we never set the upper
bounds on those preferences so we now
have caloric obesity same thing with
opportunity we weren't at what we were
wired for abundance of opportunities
we're wire for scarcity so now that we
have an abundance we just say yes to
everything and then next thing you know
you're over scheduled no no to the last
inch of your life you're probably over
schedule you're probably running a
deficit you're probably not doing some
basic function exactly like taking care
of your health
yeah we're calling mom I mean think you
should be doing yeah no seriously though
calling mom
I had a 15-minute called my mom to issue
I'm so happy that I called her anybody
called her mom this week okay a couple
of people all right I'm sure she'd love
to hear you from you
so in January I'm going to be running an
opportunity cleanse just like a caloric
cleanse I've been doing a cleanse for
years and just getting people to just
drop everything kind of doing an
elimination diet drop everything let's
start from the basics sleep calling mom
right there we're gonna get through
these things and they just realize okay
make sure you take care of the most
important things and then see what you
can actually add without having the
whole thing fall apart it's much easier
to throw everything out and pull back
any important things then try to trim
10% of your life then FOMO is gonna kick
in you're gonna put it right back it
doesn't work so you call it a time
cleanse a time cleanse opportunity
cleanse an opportunity cleanse it's a
how how many of you feel like your
schedule is just packed all the time
yeah yeah yeah it's a decent amount what
about the do you guys have something
going on in your calendar in the month
of like March already you guys have like
a planned event in March yeah
okay so I've run a empty calendar I'm
one meeting a day that's formally
scheduled this is it for today and but I
have a full day so I end up working 12
to 16 hour days but I use my Microsoft
Outlook as a diary not as a calendar so
that's a very different way and when I
think about when I encounter something
interesting I can spend the next eight
days on a straight and you know most
people I know even if they encounter
something they'd really want to do they
got to somehow put on the calendar and
they're booked out and so it's really
hard to move forward so I think really
being able to curate the opportunities
that we all face is super important
being able to say no respectfully and
not getting stretched too thin is
absolutely vital in terms of being able
to move forward now in terms of one of
the things I get involved in so now that
you know I clear my calendar what do I
literally think about and what do i how
do I make decisions each day I think was
your question and if you find something
really interesting that you want to
study you go eight straight days boom
right into it yes and this is how I've
got a lot of my personal interests off
the ground was having the time I liken
it to investing
if you're buying everything like a lot
of people are it's like buying a mutual
fund so that means you're gonna have an
average return on your life which is
totally fine really good analogy that is
a really good but if you want to have an
above-average return your life you got a
constant short your portfolio like we
tend to run very few stocks so it's in a
tongue up to you I mean at the averages
extraordinary today but if you want to
have truly extraordinary I think you've
got to say no to almost everything now
and it feels so good
how many of you guys have said no to
something and then you notice you had
time to invest in yourself afterward
yeah yeah yeah thank you it feels so
good there were a lot of people that
were asking me to help mentor them or
work with their companies and I was at
first saying yes to everything and after
saying no to a couple people it actually
felt really good very politely saying no
and wishing them the best because I
wanted to focus my time on on curating
the portfolio two of the things that I
think will make the most impact rather
than just like a mutual fund yeah I
think I think I see a lot of people
struggling with this issue you know it's
a small secret but I also try making
time is what the long dividend is all
about on the back end high quality high
quality are looking for but it's also
more as much about making time now
making time for each other
so one way the gift of time that I give
to my friends is I invite them to
meetings that don't exist as a way to
block out their calendar so they can
hide from their secretaries they cannot
relax so this is an inside joke for a
lot of people I like I'm literally
giving them time by inviting the
meetings that don't exist so they can
hide from the secretaries okay oh I'm
sorry Bob is booked from 12:00 to 1:00
and Bob's just chilling and relaxing
yeah and so this is Thank You June
please do that next week again let's do
another meeting next week standing
meeting and then okay so what do i what
do I focus on so now that I've got time
clear calendar you know I I kind of
think that most things self resolved
world is very resilient sometimes it
takes a little while to get a ride so
things that are gonna now chase
self-correct
I tend to kind of let go even its
imperfect so I tend to focus on things
that are
think are knocking a self resolved but
I'm mostly talking here about you know
philanthropy you know so our business is
investing in health care locally some
things that don't self-serve resolve
yeah things that are not gonna not set
up to self resolved so there's three
categories that I look at one is
anything that's an evolutionary
dislocation so the way are we are wired
relative to the modern context because
the context has changed so much it's now
maladaptive and it's not gonna self
resolved because we just continue to
have this hardwiring in a completely new
context so that's one in an example like
obesity like we were wired for scarcity
we never set upper bounds okay so now
that the environments change we just eat
too much opportunity yeah those are
evolution dysfunctions and the obesity
with the time wanting to fill our
calendars yeah with opportunity so
another category is a market failures so
you know we're largely a capitalistic
society and there are certain things
like you know pollution environment
these are things that capitalism isn't
going to solve because everybody's
enlightened self-interest is going to
behave in a way that doesn't resolve
that particular issue don't have it
takes some of their effort and the third
category is when there's hegemony
meaning there's oppression to the point
where it's actually something is not
just but they can't overcome it on your
own they can't resolve it on their own
so people have to step in and resolve
those injustice those are three
categories everything else that's
imperfect I just let go over time
hopefully it'll resolve it's it seems
like that in my mind is still like ten
thousand things those three things fit
like ten thousand different categories
so how do you pick out of those then
okay so anything that there's a lot of
eyeballs looking at I tend to let go so
anything that's divided 50/50 whenever
you see something is 50/50 two things
are gonna happen each side is gonna
believe each 50% is gonna believe there
are a hundred percent right and
realistically they're probably both
partially right polarization in American
politics exactly the second things can
happen it's going to attract a lot of
people so for sure this is what nature
wants as differences and the difference
is
create competition so there'll be tons
of people eyeballing that so I'm gonna
walk away from that I'm gonna focus on
the one in 99 s so I'm interested in
situations where by the way so that's a
majority-minority most of the time the
99% has it right but it's in those rare
instances when the 1% has a ride that
they're holding the truth that's when
it's interesting tonight my favorite
example is Bruno Copernicus and Galileo
to fighting against the Catholic Church
saying that the earth is not the center
of the universe and the earth just
orbits around the star Bruno was burned
at the stake in 1600 you're sitting in
front of a fire there yeah yeah so
that's exactly right and you know I
think the that's what I think it's going
to be an uncrowded trade from an
investment perspective it's gonna be
price low and I think that's the place
that you can make a big impact in terms
of one's activities so like you know
longevity is a field that a few years
ago really was vacant and if that 1% the
smoke wasn't working I were right and
that's transformative and so that's uh
so that's how I pick my battles I mean I
do almost nothing and I've pick a few
battles and I look at where is the
majority culture potentially wrong
knowing that almost all the time it's
right so I'm not trying to be contrarian
I'm not trying to the opposite most of
the time the culture is right we get it
right it's the instances were then
menorah tea might have a rise work is
really interesting exciting and Peter
teal follows a similar philosophy talks
about a zero to one the idea of finding
things that you can monopolize on
completely and things that no one else
is thinking of things that should exist
in the world but no one else is doing
and it's tough does it's tough in this
world to maybe build an app or start a
restaurant because so many other people
are doing it but if there is a mission
something that is not being done the
bigger you can think of the more you can
monopolize the more you can do do you
want to maybe touch on the low stress
and on stress oh sure about food yeah I
guess you're kind of well this is
something I did today like
ask me about a typical day so we hosted
a gathering a few weeks ago all my
favorite food scientists that I'd met on
site around the world they were saying
different things so naturally just
brought them all together here in San
Francisco and had them talked to each
other on stage and in a couple of
takeaways one is they all agreed on the
fact that they don't agree on anything
that's not a single thing on fully agree
on that was interesting right they say
that on stage the second thing was the
acknowledgment that the public is very
confused because there's so much
conflicting information about food so
you get underneath that what's the
source of all these disagreements and
it's good to have different points of
view but it's if it's chaotic you know
Aaron Weinstein talks about the semi
reliable communal sensing you got to
have something you can kind of hold on
to if all of you have different points
of views and it's as chaos then people
start becoming micro tyrants bless you
and everybody starts having the own
point of view and they start marketing
that so food right now is in a domain
where I mean there's just tons of people
that believe they're the experts because
food is now something that you can avoid
because you probably have to eat again
in the next six hours so you start
consuming your own belief system and you
start exporting to others so food right
now is getting not only is a confusing
to begin with because of Sciences very
early but now you have all these people
that all have strong views that are you
know now click baiting everybody with
those views okay so that was a hard
thing to walk away from as an event I
mean I walked in thinking okay I want to
fund food scientists and they all
acknowledge food part of the reason why
there's so much dissension is because in
a lot of the studies aren't that we
can't do long term follow-up they can
run long enough studies that they
definitely needed more money so I spent
the last few weeks kind of unpacking the
problem like ok I can't really step in
here the second problem I encounter was
the fact that there's a lot of research
that people are skeptical about sigh
kind of looked through that wire people
so skeptical some of these findings that
are being done so guess how much money
is available for food science research
through public funds
it's a first that's a really small
number one and a half billion there's no
NIH for food so scientists have to
literally cobble together small pockets
of money from CDC USDA and NIH part of
these RFP that's one and a half billion
you know how much we spend on candy per
year just to put that number into
perspective thirty-five billion dollars
so the ratio of candy consumption
thirty-five million food science 1.2 1.5
billion now the 1.5 billion is not the
total amount because turns out there's
also 12 billion coming from industry so
industry sponsored research is a quite
substantial and you know they've done a
great job of filling the gap of food
scientific research food science and
they've also you know contributed
greatly to the body of knowledge but we
can't rely on industry funding for food
science research over the long haul I
mean right now 93 wonder why 93 percent
of studies sponsored by industry that
conclude in favor the sponsor right so
long term we need something really
different than this and by the way the
more we eat the food that the sponsor
tells us the and the bigger their R&D
budget this is just gonna keep going and
going and going okay so what did I do
today I presented a white paper to some
of the leaders in the food community
with a ridiculous proposal ridiculous
proposal because I think adding another
few million to food science funding on
from the public sector against this wall
of 12 billion and private funding isn't
gonna make a difference whereas in
longevity there was no public funding or
private funding so you put a lot of
money in like everything catches fire
right and food that's not the case so I
had to kind of mentally organize a
problem differently in my mind so here
is the the most important thing to know
about food that's changed in the last
hundred years anybody know what it is
shout out the answer if you think JMO
JMO came late what's much more fun about
the main thing that changes who gave it
to you
so until the modern age we were agrarian
we actually grew our food and we fed our
own family it was very kin oriented this
is how we live so your mom would never
put in food coloring or antibiotics or
change the genes of food to give it to
you because she loved you this is why
should call her love so she had fifty
percent genetic equity in you so it's
all about you food is all about you
whereas now we've been dust realized and
now food is given to you by somebody
else a stranger that cares more about
their pockets yeah I mean they care
about you too but they care about you
second they care about themselves first
that change in order from one and two in
terms of where you are the priority
changes everything because now food
company they're gonna play the chess
game with you
every helpful movement you know they're
gonna be able to figure out a way to
make that work for them now they're
gonna make it work for you two partially
but being number two is a very
disadvantageous position so that's how
we end up with fake foods we have fake
foods today and you got to realize fake
foods and fake news have the same source
which is the fact that the source is now
other it used to be somebody that cared
about us in the olden days a chief would
give you the news they didn't know much
at least they cared about you right so
they're gonna try their best to keep you
their version of the truth it was all
about you I've been member in their
tribe mattered yeah high inclusive
fitness now we have low inclusive
fitness it's reciprocal altruism that's
the system but our brains are still
wired to trust so in the olden days the
chieftain would never tell you it drinks
right right they would tell you you know
drink water right in the modern times is
now a counterparty risk so everything is
counterparty risk whether its food or
information and now you have clickbait
because you know take this right and so
whether it's News Facebook sprite it's
all the same phenomena of the change in
alignment so I eat high Lineman food
it's a diet of one there's no data
because no one studied this but I look
for alignment what does that mean
it's it means I like the grower close to
me knowing me seeing photos so that I'm
not some counterparty to them in the
same way that our founder used to bring
our our clients to shareholder means of
companies to remind the boards this is
who you serve so really collapsing that
agency risk trying to get it to as low
as possible because right now so many
principals are getting abused by their
agents in sort of every industry and
this all came from a single change we
lived as tribes the transportation costs
went way too low communication laws all
the sudden we got mobile we went all
over and we started to be among
strangers instead of tribesman who cared
about us but we're still wired to trust
and they believe it this besides
proximity to or klore how close we are
to the person that's growing our food
and knowing where it's coming from
maybe we talked a little bit about the
low stress and unstressed foods eating
it right off of the tree okay there's no
data for this but let me look it's
referred to is and this is not what I
was working on today this is something I
was working on 10 years ago but I would
like to fund it is to really think about
food in a third way besides the first
two ways we think about today right now
we think about food is calories and
nutrition so calories doesn't you know
we need them with our support to
maintain our anti-entropic state ii
attrition is you need certain molecular
constituents like you know vitamins that
are going to help you serve your
metabolic functions right
the third category is I wonder if food
is actually content if it's information
that we're actually learning about the
world or our food and what is it telling
us is it an information source so if you
kind of go backwards in evolution right
now we have eyes and ears we have
incredible ways to learn kind of
remotely but if you're a little amoeba
the way you can learn about the world is
you can you have you can do phototaxis
you can do vibrational taxes or you do
chemo taxes chemo texans meteor sensing
the gradients that determine where you
are
and so they ate their way through the
world gut was their first braid and now
that we got complex senses were so much
more relying on non gut for sensing but
there's no doubt low organisms they use
it as an information source a really
third category and then the next
question is if that's it food is
information meaning they're signaling
we're literally receiving signals and
then we're modifying our behavior all of
this came from a small chapter I wrote
an endocrinology textbook about why is a
line affecting all of our life history
strategies because our iodine's the
basis of your thyroid hormone and
thyroid hormone has a small effect on
many major life issues decisions like
metabolic rate how long you live how
many when you undergo metamorphosis
male-female ratio but that's the total
of dietary components are you actually
reading your diet to remodel your
phenotype are you sensing this
information was the first time I had a
thought like I wonder if there's just
this whole the thing about food we've
missed as an opportunity and what I
start to think about was is food right
now stressed and therefore were actually
eating alarm calls of everybody I had I
was in the food chain because you're
when you thing about nature biology what
constant looking for opportunity and
stress right versus opportunity goes the
two agonal and you know antagonistic
states that we have because even though
we're living in a relatively low stress
environment the food chain ahead of us
is experiencing very high stress like
animals today experience tremendous
amounts of stress whether you're a cow
or chicken a million chickens per hour
in the US right and you know they're
raised in stressful conditions they're
you know they're killed in stressful
conditions all the things you read about
elsewhere from Paulo and elsewhere you
know that's all true now think about the
stress experience and their cortisol
levels and all the molecular changes
when we eat those it have effect on us I
mean are you what you eat because in
nature if you're the first to know when
the world's on fire by your diet like
you know the biggest fire the biggest
stress and nature is winter when it gets
dry and cold so
every species starts fattening up so if
everything that had to be is fattening
up you should find them in other words
obesity may be a feature not a bug
except now they're not fat because it's
winter they're fat because of the
conditions are raised in and with high
cortisol and now when we eat those obese
cows we get obesity there are
hypertensive they're diabetic oh my god
we're like getting exactly what they
have as if the stress is transferring
onto us and we can also talk about
plants with the same understanding as
well when you pluck an apple from a tree
and you eat it yeah anybody know what
the stress hormone plants are anybody
yell it off you know what is the
cortisol plants clothes ethanol ethanol
is what you're doing upstairs it's
ethylene c2h4 second simplest
hydrocarbon on the planet after meth
methane and the strange thing is I was
never taught about in biology class or
biochemistry cause there's no conspiracy
they just forgot to teach us stress
hormones of plants so here's what F lean
does it means a gas an ethylene will
lead the de plant the flower to fruit
the drop and the sweetened so any sort
of stress it could be biotic or abiotic
biotic is like getting you know a bug or
infection or by abiotic like you know
getting a cut or being plucked all those
things will Emilia activate ethylene
ethylene is what makes things sweet it's
what makes things brown so when you cut
a banana
you remember oxidative stress is the
greatest stress in nature you know when
you're seeing something ripen it's
essentially undergoing ethylene mediated
stress response that's what you're
seeing and by the way that's what you're
eating like okay what happens when you
eat ethylene when you eat what happens
if heath stressed banana
no one's ever studied it well it turns
out if you go far map back enough and
Google scholars like I did because I
have time I've got eight hours I can I
can basically you basically to a point
where there's tons of stuff in the
literature about ethylenes use and
medicine it was used as an anesthetic
but the side effects were water
retention hyperglycemia which is
diabetes
hypertension there was all the same side
effects as cortisol and it just it's
common sense when you pluck the Apple
and you eat it right away versus if it
sits in your fruit basket for a month
and then you see it a month later and it
looks like it's slightly rotten and if
you take eat that there's a big
difference that happens to your body
well yeah we don't know but the
speculation is that the hypothesis is
does eating stress food induces stress
this font in you does eating stress
stress hormones or metabolites the
stress hormones does it have an effect
on you again because if you're lying and
the thing you're eating is stress you
should probably receive it as an alarm
call because we're all wired to quickly
make the stress of others our own is
that it's a huge advantage you also want
to be the first to know when the stress
is over which is like Groundhog Day
crocus flowers in springtime so you want
to reduce your stress at that point so
the the plant the plants here's what the
plants by the way Whole Foods sprays
ethylene 7:59 the morning everything is
a gas now you know this phrase one bad
apple spoils a whole bushel if one of
one starting to ripen they all ripen
because stress is contagious we all know
that you know at work if somebody
stressed out we all get stressed out
when the markets if somebody stressed
everybody gets stressed so that's
actually a natural phenomenon because
you don't know that you've seen the lion
but if the guy next we've seen the line
you just wanna freak out too because
otherwise your gates gonna eaten so
we're all wired to make the stress of
others our own plants with the same
thing - they just quickly get stressed
if somebody nearby stress now it's whole
food stressing them out because it's
it's um it actually makes the fruit more
seductive to animals it glistens so
here's my post hoc narrative on why I
think plants might have used ethylene as
a stress hormone like why did it decide
to use c2h4 as its first form I have no
idea but so here's a little story I
wrote about why it might have done so so
what is the greatest threat to plants
what is gonna wipe out your entire
progeny maybe an infection right
drought right ecologic conditions what
about this right here you can see sorry
which I could see the way back there
okay so that fire that fake fire
simulation fire right there so you've
got just to be cognizant of our time
time yeah yeah yeah yeah okay we real
quick here so have you ever thought
about what that smoke is yeah me neither
until I had eight hours to think about
it so it's actually it's actually
ethylene among other hydrocarbon
fragments so the fire's an enormous
threat threat to the progeny of plants
because they all your children died
you've laid the groundwork for thousands
of years you know and then gone so when
a plant smells smoke it activates
flowering fruition obsession which is a
following and sweetening and their
little animals run up to it to the sweet
stuff they eat it the seat is protected
and the animal runs to me it's like
Logan's Run it's their last chance to
escape from this raging fire I made all
that up I have no idea so if that's the
case the fact that we are mass producing
ethylene today for industrial use
you know we're producing 109 million
metric tons per year it's not you the
most synthesized chemical on the planet
what is it mostly used for like plastic
it's actually a storage form of the
hydrocarbons when pull out of the ground
so how do we know we're not causing like
equal system level inflammation
inflammation is not just inside your
body what if it's the whole ecosystem
that's inflamed right now so now we'll
do a little transition we'll go into
when I asked you where you see AI and
blockchain going from here
so 25 years ago which is a long time ago
92 I took a year off in medical school
to code and build AI for medical
diagnostics it was a we had a Dean that
actually approved it because you're
supposed to do molecular research but I
thought this was far more fun there's
basically using old hebbian concepts and
building their own networks back then
because the process of power power
wasn't there we could only do three
layers and you'd go play basketball then
come back and you finished processing
and that's the response of the market
was the following they say they will
never work or we'll have no jobs those
are the two things that everybody said
everywhere and so you fast-forward where
we are now you know people are now
pretty confidence gonna work in many
applications but the fear is just
absolute incredible and if you look at
what happened in radiology so there were
basically two research groups I worked
in Kerry Floyd's lab AI is now a part of
radiology and we actually do ii reads
and radiologists busier than ever so it
both is working and humans just go to
the next level of function so when i
think about the future of AI i think
it's amazing i think it's gonna work and
i think it'll actually give us number
one more time which is great and i think
we'll be able to do better things with
her at the time because he's helping us
along the way so i'm you know i'm
optimistic about AI i'm optimistic about
blockchain over the long haul
you know i made the comment that DNA was
the very first blockchain it was very
different with different purpose right I
shared the [ __ ] out of that Facebook
post well so such a good it's a it's a
very loose analogy in the idea that it's
such a it's selection and it's the Sun
it's the sum of those selections but
very different regime and it's not
recording the full history it just
records the result of the history that's
all you have so it deletes all prior
versions through selection and then you
have this floating thing and just like
blockchain it governs the behavior of
everything around it whether it's
protein function or even all the way to
the behavior level you
so that's as such a what blockchain does
is it actually governs the behavior
everybody under you sort of agreed yeah
you have a billion dollars right this is
essentially what it's doing but it's
very different you know the the living
system code is so much more robust
because of the lack of fidelity because
it can mutate and now she can drive its
own selection process whereas right now
blockchains functions very different we
want hundred percent fidelity we can't
afford not to so it'll be interesting
and I think blockchain uses our you know
manifold we can't even imagine what they
are right now I do worry that it's going
to become a massive source of inequality
because it's happening so fast and
there's so much concentration of power
there's a lots of power transfer and
wealth transfer that's happening right
now and as much as people are trying to
focus on equality there they've
completed forgot to think this through
in terms the effect that's gonna have on
society so I worry about that a lot yeah
so maybe we we touch on this a little
bit
I love the analogy of DNA it would be
fascinating if there was like an actual
ledger in the past four billion years of
how this actually became what it was all
the mutations ever would be so
fascinating
maybe we touch a little bit on on one of
blockchains many applications which is
cryptocurrency let's talk about Bitcoin
just a little bit this is a really
really interesting thing why don't maybe
you just jump in okay about the impact
economy or maybe by the way the fact
that Nature doesn't care about history
tells us something right because we
might care that you bought Bitcoin of
five bucks and bought a pizza for Tony
with it right but but the system doesn't
care and why should we care that what
you did with it back then it's really
where do we stand now that's why nature
in some ways you know does doesn't does
doesn't care and and in that way I think
it's you know right now block chains one
hundred forty megabytes you know it but
it can't grow infinitely so nature's
already thought through all that and
just decided we're just gonna keep the
active record are the results of all
that history the sum of all those
transactions okay maybe we start with
this question of how much money has gone
into Bitcoin okay so how much money has
alright when you put money into a
private company like an angel investment
where ism
goes onto the balance sheet of the
company right how much money has gone in
the Bitcoin everybody keeps talking
about how much money has gone in the
Bitcoin how much money has gone in the
Bitcoin right now or more importantly
where does it go
okay billions right in reality money
doesn't go in the Bitcoin remember when
you are selling something directly like
when you when somebody sells your
private company stock that money goes in
their balance sheet let's go so if you
put them put a million dollars in the
value of the company it's probably not
gonna be less than a billion because
there's a billion on the balance sheet
there's not your cash in there your cash
goes there when you buy a Bitcoin it
doesn't go in the Bitcoin it goes to the
person that just bought it from you so
that's very different than putting
something directly in it's basically a
transaction side to side you know your
million went to their million their
Bitcoin came to you and then the system
Bitcoin system still has no cash so
there's nothing to catch it as it starts
to fall so as it goes from valuation of
you know 1 million to 240 billion right
now that's all mark-to-market expansion
of balance sheet now essentially we're
signing value to that and we're saying
it's worth as much but if people decide
it's not worth that much it's not like
there's a hundred billion the bag
that'll stop it from collapsing so this
is a very important thing to know about
finance but this in many way maze I
think bitcoin is showing us the
fundamental flaw of the entire financial
system the entire financial system is
based on this idea of mark-to-market so
if you decide that Apple is worth one
more dollar than it was yesterday
everybody else gets to mark it up so
even though you put one more dollar and
there's system l2 the value the
expansion of the balance sheet overall
everybody marks that everybody feels
wealthier so the amplification of every
trade is massive in the modern world and
then that money goes to invest in
something else which goes to invest in
something else so there's this massive
increase in liquidity that happens with
nothing except change in price no value
has been created no money's been put
into the system everything went silent
silence so what you're seeing in
blockchain is literally as Bitcoin
successful they use some of that
investment crypto price of that goes up
these some of that to go over there so
you're having this massive expansion of
balance sheet which probably is going to
spill over into real assets to cause
inflation there but as it starts that
this
inflate the same thing happens the way
down as prices fall everybody has to
market down so the balance sheet
contraption is out of proportion yeah to
the price the change in price of that
one thing so the this is a really
bizarre situation that means as prices
are rising in a way relative to demand
it's not you're getting cheaper because
the demand is increasing across the
board for everything as prices are
falling relative because your balance
sheets everywhere contracting so fast
things are actually getting more
expensive relative liquid this is a
total bizarre scenario Saul ways been in
place in finance except in finance you
had other ways to value as such as cash
flow or revenues and in blockchain
there's no one way to value it there's
no one way there's no way people can
agree
so the chaos of that is gonna lead to
huge volatility and instability and that
could spill over to the real economy
which is you know you're now you're
gonna have the dog at the tail wagging
the dog right you can have you can have
the crypto an economy start to wag the
whole economic dog so I think that's
Sarah we need to think through I mean
these are you know the great
technologies but the way the way the
market is taking off right now actually
is creating risk into the market and the
way that different cryptocurrencies are
structured financially are different
with Bitcoin it's a limited amount of
coin 21 million and that makes it that
treats it more like a goal it's a
deflationary currency there's only a
limited amount of it whereas with the
theory amor other cryptocurrencies there
is steady inflation of the total amount
of tradable currency so then so that
that's it's a that's differently with
this way that you're viewing it yes well
I kind of think about it if you have to
devalue is it the more you can print it
what oh yeah yeah yeah absolutely we
actually we can do a question now we can
um we were gonna wait until the end but
if you you seem like you're excited well
you seem like you're excited sure let's
go for
aspects this drug Bitcoin and watching
the applications essentially open-source
money within society we've had close
source money where we now have open
source protocols to exchange value kind
of like well the good news is whether
that will be entirely determined by well
almost until you determine by people
like we decide that that's what's gonna
hold value and the only the reason I had
to little bit because Outsiders can
still try to step in and say that's not
the case as a currency is is I don't
know but blockchain is a technology and
what you can build on top of that yeah
is such a good one imagine make gorgeous
I mean I think this is gonna be and it
may things about the equity of that
because I did the did the inequality
that's already existing I think it's
gonna cause a lot of a lot of a lot of
issues and the way we're going right now
and there seems to be like you just said
there seems to be a lot of hype and
interest around what a blockchain is and
different applications and different
ways to structure it but with the sense
of just investing into one single
cryptocurrency that we don't quite know
exactly but we're very sure about like a
blockchain being something really
interesting to explore maybe maybe we
talk a little bit about I kind of want
to I want to kind of because we were
talking about AI a little bit not not
too much but do you think that we hope
that there is that this is one of the
risks that we face and what are maybe
some of the other risks that
we face as a society so the I mean I
think about risk it's not the technology
risk per se but it's a human risk so
counterparty risk to me is the main
thing so AI can be used for a lot of
good but it can also be used if you want
to maximize clickbait as a media engine
you can now use AI to scale your
activities you don't have to sit there
and let give you the news you want it
can now generate it intentionally and
then generate automatically and then you
can end up promoting division and
society this was in the news in the last
couple days but this has been in place
forever
through media so the things I worry
about on a large scale is counterparty
risk the fact that we we're not awake to
this issue that we're dealing with
counterparties and the fact that that
that lack of insight being exploited to
me is just gonna continue to cause
problems in every industry food politics
media these are all counterparty risk
models now I think that's a that's the
main thing I worry about and then I
worry about this financial risk and the
third thing I worry about is the sort of
fear pandemic that tends to happen every
once in a while
again we're wired for fear but now that
we're hyper connected the this now has
plague-like potential you know how many
cases of Zika they were this year
validated one so I know when it was
happening and how all this architecture
of something that people were gonna
start to turn into a fear epidemic you
know when when a stars came out I wrote
a fake parody piece called I'm sorry
swine flu swine flu fear as the virus
SFF I didn't call it so I felt like it
was an epidemic going on and there's
tons of tons of pigs are getting
slaughtered it literally got sent back
to me by a friend of mine who said are
you keeping your home kids home from
school for because SFF because I'm
keeping mine home like what that was the
whole thing was a parody so we're now we
living at a time where people just
literally are forwarding articles they
did
read you just read the headline you know
this is what everybody does right nobody
reads these articles at the for the
headline and that's really dangerous
because these are and you know that the
way I can see these things occurs when
you have an on round number as the
number of deaths it makes it more real
so it'll be like 43 deaths if you hear
hundred your mind doesn't think that's
real when you hear 43 the specificity
you you will overweight that okay week
that's like that's serious there and
then you can throw confirmation bias
convince yourself that it's causing you
know this and that and and by the way
most of those diagnosis it was all the
symptoms were sneezing coughing fever
like wait a minute that's like every
virus so that's what I worry about more
is this is just one example the the fear
pandemic on everything right now I mean
it could be about terrorism it could be
about you know might Michael microbes
it's amazing the rapidity by which it
can go around the world right now and go
around multiple times around the world
okay those are my three words
so I'm cautiously optimistic about the
future I'm optimistic then what are your
thoughts about collectivism versus
individualism okay so this is like group
versus individual so the honest truth
that we should all have is we are both
we are we are both collectivists and
individualists and and so we have okay
that's another example of parallax we
have an internal parallax what we want
for ourselves a movie or for society and
they don't often line up look at a car
they think about it right there's the
hindbrain of what I want to do the
4-minute oh no that's not a good idea so
then you think about society at large
there's this there's sort of this
publicly there's a we got to do good
philosophy which is very important and
privately people do what they want to do
so we might be like hey let's be
environmentalists and then you know and
then on the drive home they like throw
out the trash so if you look at highway
101 we are voted as a number one
environmentally friendly state by the
conscious state and we are the filthiest
highways so it's not they it's us right
we are actually were the ones doing it
so we have this aspirations to be a
certain way
to be just to be good but that's what we
really want other people to do and we
hope you can do that too and we're all
and we need a new word than hypocrisy
because we need to win your new taxonomy
most Hippocrates is not intentional I
don't think we're bad people like I was
drinking that I cook well telling my
kids they couldn't add Diet Coke and so
when I asked Eric you know can you
please I taught him the word hypocrite
and use it right back my daddy thinks
that cocaine he won't let me have any
anyway so I wasn't intending to be a
hypocrite so we do this as a
compartmentalization so we can survive
because it's really hard to do both
right this is also the reason why
historically the media has been more
liberal because media is we were we are
putting up a public front so in the
history of media it's always been more
liberal this is what we aspire to and
then here's the reality it read the
comment sections of media that's what we
you know that that's the same people
that are saying all these amazing things
and then saying all these other things
and anonymously so we have to realize
these aren't us versus them it's us it's
our own personal parallax we want to be
aspirational we want to be great
and sometimes we fall short now if we
can narrow that gap that will be amazing
for it and it can maybe we touch on it
in terms of some of these up-and-coming
societal projects that we're working on
things like artificial general
intelligence and colonizing Mars and
things like that are we going there
together are we trying to build out this
collectively so the most important thing
is to be dynamic in our thinking there
are times when it makes sense nature
doesn't want us to you to always think
about the group either because you got
to think about yourself cuz the group's
agenda may be very current productive
for you and if the cover to every
individual then the groups are going to
sink so you have to be dynamic the key
things that not have fixed views so when
it comes to politics here's what I heard
from key is to not have fixed yeah the
key is to so be open minded yes
socialism capitalism neither really work
and so the best we can do is to when it
gets over extended the one percent
create the counterculture and then drive
it back the other way that's the whole
history because there is actually no
right answer those things and that's why
it's always dynamic so I think we should
have be elastic we should be forgiving
of
each other so okay so here's what I
heard and I always hear from the
libertarians like in New Hampshire live
free or die
they live on 200 acres and they say I
need guns because if I call the police
they'll be here in two days I don't
understand why they can tell me to turn
down the radio and a noise ordinance I
don't understand where their stops signs
because there's no traffic there's
nobody here I see no evidence of social
services now if you talk to somebody in
San Francisco living in the Millennium
say you know they can't turn on the
radio next door I can hear them if you
didn't have stop signs we'll all crash
into each other I see everyday evidence
of social services and if y'all had
against will shoot each other so think
about the common ground between the
right and the left is we all want to
maximize their freedom the difference is
in one case it's high-density so we got
to constrain our freedoms my freedom
ends when yours begins and on the right
you can maximize your freedom because
nobody around you think about freedom as
bumper-car so you can go you can drive
wherever you want but your freedom ends
when you hit somebody so you know I've
got libertarians out literally in New
York City that'll drive on the sidewalk
because they can't stand the fact that
you have to stop that is all about it
that's a very fixed view right and
you've got you've got people you know
liberals going into these other places
and preaching you know their thing these
fixed views is where we get into trouble
we should be dynamic like eyes are
driving from the from sacrum or from
Modesto to here you should be changing
color if you're a red out there because
you can inflate your freedom but if you
get in here you got to put you know
again your freedom ends when there's
begins like you don't have the freedom
even if you're libertarian to punch
somebody because that reduces their
freedom so this is a way to really
consolidate everything we thought about
humanism will the last 500 years and
think dynamically and you solve for it
with a single variable instead of
disagreeing on these things so when I
think about collectivism versus
individualism there's actually no right
answer just again be be contextual think
about it be generous and be kind and try
to make a good decision within that
context good stuff now
I you you know you've taught of me about
this quite a bit and I want to see if
this resonates with other people it
seems as though we have moved on from
having five or six children per two
people to having maybe one or two people
per two children in developed countries
and so as the world becomes a developed
world it doesn't look like we're going
to 10 billion 20 billion 30 billion it
looks like yeah I love this one because
again we have fixed views about multis
in fears so this fear that we're gonna
run out of everything because population
growth is the demography is gonna ruin
everything we're going to run our
resources ruin the environment and W
famine all that those are the those were
in multiples in those books and then in
our generation or right beef generation
before us it was a Paul era which that
wrote the book Population Bomb you know
he was essentially exploiting the Cold
War fears bomb was the big thing we
feared back in the 60s so put the word
population Malthus and bomb and then the
bestseller and so it was a lagging
indicator population growth rates peaked
after the year wrote the book it has
been going down ever since I maybe had a
positive effect that I don't know but
this idea that if we keep living longer
will fill the planet is the story but
empirically it's the exact opposite so
right now every single first of all
country the replacement rate is under
one so you know the TED talk two years
ago earth is full everybody still
fear-mongering about population growth
so markets that were here and the data
is over here that we're actually
stabilizing as countries go from third
world to first world every first world
country then starts depopulating so
directionally if those two trends
continue population could stabilize
again you can start agreeing I mean you
know these things can always change
course but right now the fears are not
being borne out now in fact right now
one of the biggest threats is
depopulation not having enough yes
places like Japan Korea and Japan it's
all way under two per couple US Canada
Australia way under two New Zealand all
of Europe is under two per couple yeah
meanwhile comes some countries in Africa
are still at six right so the third one
stole supplying us talent I mean we call
that immigration and that's a good thing
that's a good thing right I mean so
we're gonna soon get to a point where
we're gonna realize the scarcest capital
in the world but they're serious
resource is a natural resources remember
you have human capital right yeah so in
1960s when we after reading Paula rich
all of us read it apparently we started
going to war for oil like okay now that
we're gonna run out everything we got a
horde let's fight
so in the future when we realize humans
are the scarcest resource Wars gonna
look insane right because you're
actually reducing each other's most
precious resource the war over oil is
gonna end when we realize humans are
more rare than oil right yeah
environmentalism right now it's a moral
obligation I mean environment once
people started leaving these things
environments got incredible reasons
we're gonna heal a lot of these things
there's gonna be incredible reduction of
stress on infrastructure in other words
this isn't necessary bad thing the fact
that we're now stabilizing and and then
immigration right again when we realize
that humans are the most important
resource we're going to be doing the
best we can we're not gonna build walls
we're gonna be doing the best we can to
be attractive to immigrants and we're
gonna compete for talent right you know
right now Japan can't get immigration
because they don't our citizenship so in
the future maybe they will so imagine
all these countries in the around the
world trying to be the best country
possible to attract immigrants this is
the world that were actually we're
heading into this is good news guys it
with human capital being so important is
there potentially a way to continue this
capitalistic model of really loving
innovation and fostering innovation
across the world but also finding some
love across these borders and working
together towards more collective
thoughts
competition is going to wane because you
know a concentration of humans do does
create competition right and that's
known so as the the concentration
pressure recedes you're going to go from
again the scarcity mindset to an
abundance mindset which a lot of people
are talking about where the basis of
human relationships shift more from
competition to collaboration they'll
still be competition they're probably a
lot of a really fun it would be like
things like sports
won't be as life and death and there'll
be a collaborative spirit around these
things the other way to you know always
encourage collaboration it says always
have high aims low aims will generate
competition right because that's when
you people start dividing pies because
that's the only way to get more as it
get more so low returns aren't gonna get
you there but if you aim for really high
missions it'll always unite people
because they know that their small
pieces worth a lot so I think as long as
we maintain that very high trajectory
you you seem pretty optimistic about the
future
most people stress out about the
environment or stress out about AI or
stressed out about all these different
issues but you seem like we're going to
figure out figure it out
well I'm cautiously optimistic and in
the sense there's always risk I
acknowledge the risks that are out there
I tend to agree with most of them but I
also have faith in humanity people
figure it out I think that self
resilience of societies is another
another future of evolution and living
systems so I know I think we'll you know
what we're imperfect but I think we'll
move forward I think what was our most
things and the things that we can't
resolve other things that I think are
worth working on what is the greatest
opportunity for positive change the
greatest opportunity for positive change
so the one of the major ability
dysfunctions is essentially puberty so
here's what I mean by this how many
people think that their kids can see
things that they can't see anymore like
young generation they're seers right
definitely so so until age 12 your mind
acts like a camera you can see
everything and at age 12 your mind
literally switches from a camera to a
projector and you don't realize it so
the vast majority of our ability to see
and listen gets taken away from us of
puberty and here's the Darwinian
template remember the average lifespan
on the planet was about 22 until 1800
right so the idea being opened to the
world for 12 years undergoing
metamorphosis in humans we call it
puberty and then executing on what you
learned was a pretty reasonable template
in the modern world two things have
changed we're not dying at 22
we live into 100 I mean wouldn't it be
nice if you gave be mentally open for
more than 12 years I mean how about 40
years that'd be nice
the loss of that function which no one
is named I wrote a piece on this called
plasticity but that's not even a great
word but that ten years ago wrote about
business function so at 12 because we
can no longer hear and see we can't
learn languages we can't learn you know
you can you can you can fake it but
you'll never own it like before age 12
this is the reason why teenagers act
like they know it all because they're
supposed to know it all and yet we know
they know nothing so we keep him under
house arrest until they're 18 but these
things are all Darwin dysfunctions no
one's ever written about this the second
issue is the world you deconstructed the
first 12 years changes on you because in
the olden days the world you live in it
was really died in but be given the pace
of change yeah everything changes so
whatever you absorb is now maladaptive
you end up with generation gaps end up
with inability or reserve technology so
to me that don't we in dysfunction that
dentalman limitation the fact that we
lose our camera at 12 is a single bigger
kid at biggest cows for change like I
don't think longevity is hard
I don't think politics is hard I don't
think education czar I think what's hard
is brain this is what gets in our way
how do we keep the camera so forth so if
you can figure out a way to switch that
one variable
I think cancer will solve itself I think
scientists our minds are the problem I
think politics will solve itself how to
unprogrammed that so we can be in that
childlike state for a whole lot longer
that to me is the biggest leverage point
for everything I'd rather solve the
underlying problem that's getting the
way of us being able to know we learn
the world again not tomorrow let's maybe
we're coming to hear about how you can
do this better even while we're waiting
yeah yeah that's it well okay so let me
tell you some like a biologic targets so
we know that testosterone makes us flip
so if you take a songbird that's a
juvenile and you inject testosterone
they can sing everything they've been
singing perfectly and they won't be able
to learn new songs they'd shut their
minds up and fortune estrogen does the
same
- so we know that those things are
potentially druggable targets but let's
think about non drug ways because that's
better Wow first for sure some of these
psycho dogs I think is I was gonna get
us there - but yes we have some in the
back actually but here the things we can
do that don't require taking anything in
so how do you open your money you beget
in a childlike state again the first is
to change your environment or we could
change yourself but easier to change
your environment so if you go to a place
that is complete and familiar your mind
will now get back into childlike state
ok I don't know this so you'd be more
humble and you'll absorb more it also
slow down time remember how slow
childhood was that's somewhere when
you're eight versus now so when you a
day at Burning Man will feel like a
month and you'll be and you'll be in a
childlike state so it's a way to kind of
recreate that childhood the second way
is to do improv how many people here
have done improv whoa okay yeah so
improv is all about
okay well we'll talk about that later so
so improv is another way to kind of get
back in that childlike state and then
you're kind of in flow and you're
letting go yeah so yeah I got an improv
by accident about ten years ago the
story let's let's come back to this okay
yeah and I highly recommend improv and
the third thing is to be around seers
the easiest does it go to children
they'll show you stuff you kids anymore
just but be around other people in your
community like their seers out there
they still have their camera on yeah so
what are your thoughts about free will I
mean you have agency right we were we're
told its nature and nurture
I mean know there's nature nurture and
agency you you can decide to go against
both what you're taught and what you're
born with so in that sense I think
humans have ability to do something
different but you know you can make the
meta argument that even your decision to
do that is all you know programming
there are things like our 5050 I'm gonna
let other people debate this it's so
interesting so
so this is looping it back to the
beginning when June said that things
that people are split 50/50 on he
typically doesn't go in and touch into
it probably both right and right
comparatively yes and then there things
that people aren't seeing is what you
really like to get into and try and
plant a seed in and spur other people to
get excited about and go into further
research and like I I don't
I'm not telling other people to do it
that's how I live because that's what I
want to do people are like that however
they want to be your I think you're in
that sense that's just a choice that's
my that's my personal that's my personal
choice so what do we do after we solve
everything okay so after we solve
longevity food blockchain financial
system plus the city after all that and
I actually think that we're gonna solve
everything let's just say 5,000 years
from that we've solved everything what
what are we going to do with the hubris
of Silicon Valley will be 50 yeah okay
way so 55 or 50 or some length of time
I'm just gonna say 5,000 so I think
we're gonna be doing exactly the same
thing we were doing until five thousand
years ago which is we're gonna sit
around the fire like this women tell
stories we're gonna sing dance and we're
gonna look back at this window of time
as the only abnormal period of history
this is the great interval capital J
capital I this is the only freak show
everything before then at the beam of
time was the same everything after that
will be
and the problem that will emerge
immediately and the opportunity will be
the love story it'll literally come down
to the love story once again boy girl
not seeing eye to eye but falling in
love you know this is the neverending
story that's great dude and you have a
you have a young and that's currently in
that process and you're getting to
observe it yeah I've got two boys you
the older ones in love and being a dad
and seeing it all happen that's so you
said this so you think Lissa you think
this is a really abnormal period of
human evolution everything in the past
this sort of tribalism or this sort of
um hanging out around the fire and
tongue poetry dancing singing having fun
eating is gonna be the same like 5,000
years from now but this sort of period
of time this great interval what would
you like categorize it with as making a
different call it extraordinary this is
the hunting period this is the this is
the hustle and the bustle of the 10,000
years you know I'm there almost sounds
negative this is extraordinary period
but ordinary is beautiful you know
that's my favorite something right but
nowadays my favorite subject because in
a world of clickbait the things that are
ordinary now complete overlooked and to
me those are the most amazing like when
a bee lands on a flower or when someone
holds a door open and smiles yes to me
flower is part of like flowers clickbait
I'm thinking about the bark on the tree
that's everywhere right the things that
get complete ignored like I would
literally sit there in front of an ATM
and like wonder how in the world did I
put this thing in punch a bunch of
things and I got money out and nobody
stole this is so amazing this has never
happened in human history I'll be like
at an airport and like I'm watching
luggage go around the carousel and
everybody grabs theirs and they go home
like I'm like how is this possible I'm
amazed by the ordinary these things are
but like a rose a rose leaf Rose traffic
the red lights green lights pedestrians
bicyclists are mine I can't track these
unbelievable things that are everywhere
like like I
my favorite my favorite plant is the
weed like why are they so successful
they grow everywhere with the world of
focus on you know a rose which is being
a poetical port right that's like when
we click babe but we got everywhere
botanical porn is the rose and what else
like what do you think is the most
populous fish in the ocean salmon tuna
it's called the Bristol mouth there's
literally 1,000 trillion of those
there's a quadrillion of those and yeah
we're like try to swim with the dolphins
right now they're not even a fish so
we're so focused on the extraordinary
but we should also wonder why are these
other things so prevalent like why do so
many things the body don't fail they
just don't go wrong astoundingly and
there's no money to study what goes well
we only put money into things that start
to break right so I love being in awe of
yeah of those things that are just
ordinary Ordinaries the new
extraordinary because everybody's so
focused an extraordinary right I'm
thinking that's the 1% Ordinaries now
the 1% yeah so so basically get high on
the ordinary things in existence if you
want to again it's your choice I mean
yeah I love it it's really it's it's a
good way to put it and the more that I
do that the more that I realize I'm
happy I want to finish the with a love
story about my son
so he's been dating his girlfriend for 3
years and he's 15 them so I think I have
to think love as the end would be
married by now if it was 200 years oh my
god they'd be in virtually I was 13 and
maybe you know they'd be on their second
child by now right
this by the way is one of the reasons
why I think people are getting married
at 13 is because of longevity right in
the olden days when you're you know
mortality rates were very high to
infancy chance of dying though puberty
was 50% half your siblings gonna be
there chances are one of your parents
already dead by the time your crew buddy
and then you can expect to live another
nine years try to marry and have kids so
that was your loop right that's what
you're born with and so every fairy tale
is about death
every song was about that because death
was everywhere now there's almost no
death and you're not dying at 22 so it
made sense for Juliet to hook up with
Romeo when she was 13 because you know
you're gonna run out of time so you can
realize like the idea of a marriage back
then was a pretty small promise because
even if you say I'll stay with you till
death it was a part that was only 9
years right so even if you make a bad
call it's only 9 years of hell whereas
now you make a bad call it's now 87
years if you're gonna live to 100 so
most people choose not to say I do at
their team they just delay it they start
to do more due diligence date more 20s
30s and then maybe you'll run out of
time and you might have one kid so but
why is this the whole thing a love story
again I think love is if you if you're
the one take over here is it doesn't
matter what the question is the answer
probably is love the unconditional love
so let me describe what that means so
you know the way we raise our boys is
the way I was raised which is to give
them Running Room to fall in love with
the world and you know our kids play
these things that I never thought they
wouldn't might my kids play golf like I
wouldn't play golf for them but they
love golf and through golf they've
learned the world they've learned lots
of other things you know they play music
and we didn't we didn't nothing but just
give him Running Room and just make sure
they stay out of trouble and that's
again that's the way we were all raised
back in the farm and so when I think
about how much they've learned to what
they love love is actually what makes
you learn and falling in love with the
world is what kids do best
yeah kids fall madly in love with the
world we were all there you all remember
that feeling of how much we're in love
with the world and then you start
falling in love with a gender and
everything you love about them become
your interest like I didn't need red
meat until I met Kimberly and now in
love right mean I didn't like cars she
loved cars I like cars and then you have
kids and everything your kids do you
fall in love with so imagine now
starting to pay attention again as a
sorting variable what if we started
asking your friends hey what do you love
and pay attention to that so I I've been
to Berkeley many times I didn't get
Berkeley but I knew my friend like
so you know I asked her can you take our
family to show us your Berkeley
transformative I didn't like rock
climbing but one of our friends is a
rock climber
she's a 15-3 so can you show us your
rock climbing it was like intoxicating
so if you can use love as the kernel
it's a way to get back into that state
that we all were when we can fall madly
nut would think so be around your
friends and family and ask them what
they love and pay deep attention and be
with them I love it so we'll go ahead
and open the floor for some questions we
touched on a lot of topics so pick yeah
we got a excitement over here
are largely not invest in Bitcoin so my
question is to you is is it that the
issue may be a panic amongst the general
population
yeah and to clarify right now I'm not
worried it's when it goes up tenfold to
100 fold from here what will happen is
the most conservative organizations will
get at the exactly the wrong time so
once it shows up on the balance sheets
of financial intermediaries that are too
big to fail remember like they're
working on 2 to 3% margin so these kind
of wild swings on assets that are
volatile on their balance sheets can
literally make these financial
institutions not solve it this is kind
of what happened in oh wait except now
we're dealing with an asset class that
can swing wildly now remember like these
things cost problems on balance sheets
of these intermediaries even on the
upside it becomes 10% it actually
creates other sorts of issues so it what
you don't want is that the convergence
of all these scenarios were the
financial entities in and let's say it's
five years from now because it's you
know now a seven show in the asset class
and there's a compression and then it
starts having these Domino effects and
it's not really the contagion of here
per se this is now mechanistic and that
these market and market system that we
have actually leads to its own set of
issues that are feet forward I starts
getting markdown and other people have
to markdown they have a demand for
liquidity and source it'll start that
will start being a contagion among the
financial institutions not the public is
the public panic there'll be a public
panic too obviously but the contagion
effect is the fact that as this mark
this is Mark sit down that devalues our
whole franchise they have liquidy terms
that forces them to sell something else
that goes down as well and that's what I
saw a no it is a feed-forward sell-off
that was happening across asset classes
hopefully that addressed your question
and if not always afterward and also yes
but I basically he's an author
well so the message is great and he may
be quoting from the book telomere effect
which Elissa EPEL and Liz Blackburn
wrote because they actually talked about
this Elizabeth Blackburn was a novella
right that discovered telomerase along
with two other scientists so they
apparently have shown I haven't read the
original paper that there is this
elasticity to telomeres that you can
actually lengthen it through happiness
reduction of stress friendship family
all those things without that sure would
be nice if that was the case I mean I
think that makes intuitive sense you
know stress reduction reduction of
chronic stress is definitely a good
thing
I personally believe in more dynamism
again not happiness per se but it's the
alternation between different states
that actually builds resilience so
that's the project were working on
longevity in May I didn't want to spend
today talking about it because that that
talk is all over the internet of the
future of longevity which is instead of
Wacom bowling failures really solve the
underlying problem which is loss of
resilience and the best way to improve
your resilience is to use small amounts
of stress to build your allostatic
capacity so number one we're going to
start measuring your body's Diagnostics
more dynamically kind of four
dimensionally over time we're going to
improve your state which hopefully will
map the telomeres but tell'em is just
one biomarker and do you guys want to
hear this I mean this is this is what
we're gonna be working on 2018 we're
gonna launch a clinical trial that's
gonna reinvent hopefully lifestyle
medicine to because what are we told for
longevity right now for lifestyle what
what's the best way to improve your
health my thought was exercise and diet
we're gonna make the case that it's
actually not those things but it's the
change of exercise and change of diet
because anything you do that's fixed
that's non dynamic you're actually
reducing your buffers so it's the it's
gonna be interval training for exercise
what you do when you do it
what muscle groups for diet it's not
gonna be eat this or eat that it's gonna
be eat a dynamic diet so you don't lose
metabolic capacity and the clinical
trial we're gonna start at UCSF is
interval training for breathing like
hyper it's not breathing or deep
breathing it's alternating
hyperventilation with hypoventilation
because everything about our world right
now is narrowing our dynamic range we're
supposed to be in sunlight during the
day darkness at night instead of you
know we have too much light during
nighttime like now and then too little
night during the day were under roofs
mm-hmm we're supposed to live in an
ambient temperature every species on the
planet live in ambient temperature it
lived in when it was 40 degrees 100
degrees now we try to be 70 degrees all
the time your clothes
we have HVAC systems when we move to
Palo Alto all of these things are
actually deep conditioning our body so
we've got more brittle we're losing
dynamic range so the best way to restore
that is to do the exact opposite start
stretching yourself exposing yourself
you know spend more time in the
mountains go diving
go to the desert yeah have at least one
bag of durian once a month because if
you just eat that one fixed diet that
you were told to you're gonna lose
metabolic capacity so it's gonna be much
more dynamic so we're gonna reinvent
lifestyle medicine and start doing
clinical trials to show that it really
we should be thinking four dimensionally
about this instead of just three
dimensional this one state right yeah
yeah let's do another question
population is good question yeah I mean
so to date longevity is being met by
significant decline of fertility so if
you March that out and I don't think
it's gonna continue you'll essentially
have long live populations with almost
no replacement so it was still kind of
stabilized I mean it's almost like
Nature has these you know feedback loops
so that it just reached it's something
asymptotic but let's say that's not the
case let's say people started having
miracle babies or they started having
test-tube babies so yeah I mean so there
will always be death right immortality
is not what people are talking about
most people are talking about we're
talking about a sustained health and you
get longevity as a call option we'll see
how long you live before just remember
that right now the reason we are all
gone by 120 because your mortality rate
until age 40 is what anybody know what's
the average annual mortality rate until
40 it's point one percent very low the
chance of dying each year is one in a
thousand so if we can maintain that
state of health you would live
statistically way beyond 120 you would
live till statistically how long
thousand years right nice you said it
not me yeah but what happens at 40 your
your homeostatic capacity starts
declining your ability to respond
everything starts unraveling you know
the same way they can ride roller
coasters or tolerant temperature very
answer go up to tau because the altitude
we come from injury or night you know my
eyes don't focus anymore and it's too
dark and night all the end my sugars and
some people sugars on recenter blockers
doesn't recenter the ability to monitor
cancer cancer surveillance cells don't
do the work themselves don't do the work
so you start having these features of
aging people telling you what rate goes
up every year as a population after 40
until 120 it's 100% so the
main cause of not having longevity is
the fact that we die so not dying is the
best way to promote longevity so that's
why we want to focus on maintaining high
only set of capacity try to keep your
mortality rate low every year way past
40 and let's see what happens that's and
just maybe to follow up a little bit
more on that question is so what happens
then right now we die at a price oh yeah
we done but but but let's let's say that
I'm I'm 80 and I have one child that
then has a child so there's three of us
alive right three population but then if
I'm living in till 100 or 120 there
might be four or five of us alive in
that and what happens to the population
would grow and again I believe in self
correction of society at that point we'd
probably start trying to inhabit other
planets now right now space travel is a
intergenerational game you will not live
long enough to get to most of these
places but if you have longevity it
could be your own journey right instead
of having to live and die and have kids
on these spaceships so I you know I
think we'll figure it out if we're truly
living that long I think you know
actually we'll live long enough to
accumulate enough memes enough knowledge
to solve some of these technical
problems and you know get there so and I
want to maybe ask you about what you
think will change culturally as change
when we're getting married at 13 now
we're getting married maybe at 30 and
having one kid in developed countries
what do you think will change when we're
guaranteed 120 or 150 years and so
there's no guarantee so the mortality
rate 0.1 percent a year is trauma and
infection
slings and arrows of life like Hamlet
said right so there will always be that
that rate at you persist your whole life
so you know you'll just calculate your
eyes a little differently like you know
going on an airplane it's one in two
million rides but if you're living a
long time I mean I know all those risks
will still come home at some point so
I'll be huge variants some people still
die at age one some people might live
way past the median but death will
always be there I think mortality rate
will still be 100 percent one way or
another based on what I can see now so I
think we'll take more questions
be upstairs I want to thank you guys for
coming out on a thank Joon Yoon for
being our guest today we could we're
gonna have a little bit more mingling so
stick around for some more wine and some
more food and some more conversation
maybe ask one another about what you
love and have that have that
conversation so do you have anything up
and coming that you want to plug no
happy holidays happy holidays to
everyone so some stuff we're learning
out some stuff for the 2018 is looking
like we're gonna try and ramp this up
and potentially turn into the weekly
talk show and you guys please do do you
guys have a good time all right good
yeah yeah those have more of these
conversations let's inspire more people
to have them as well and besides that
you please do follow up with one another
follow up with us online we'd love to
hear from you about maybe other
questions that you would like to have
asked on the show and I think that's
pretty much it the unconditional love
thank you thank you
[Applause]